uh well let's pick up on that with the
chair of the labor party annaly studs
good to see you Ms Dodds um the
situation in manston as admitted by the
government Minister this morning is
unacceptable and it is illegal but it
does feel as if there are efforts being
taken now to try and improve what is
going on inside there well there really
need to be those efforts I think that
footage is incredibly concerning and
hearing about the level of disease now
circulating at that facility it's very
worrying actually that we have a Home
Secretary who was warned about this
situation in fact whose officials said
she needed to deal with it but chose not
to and I think this ultimately does
underline that the Prime Minister has to
get a grip on this it looks like he was
forced by his party to actually accept
that Home Secretary you know really he
should be putting people first in our
country first not his party so so when
Rishi sunak said yesterday you can't
attack a plan if you don't have a plan
but what is Labor's plan to deal with
this because frankly we've had 12 years
of the conservative government who say
that there are no committee to stopping
boots coming across but you know frankly
that there hasn't been a solution put
forward yet that would remove the risk
of people putting their own lives at
risk let's remember what is going on in
the channel in Thailand well exactly and
this is a horrendous situation and so
dangerous for people attempting that
journey and labor has set out a number
of measures that the government should
take I mean we've been calling for
months for example for the government to
stop wasting money 140 million pounds on
their Rwanda scheme that schemes
unworkable it's unethical so expensive
they should instead use that money put
it into the National Crime agency with a
special cell to crack down on the people
Smugglers we've been calling for that
for a very long time they haven't
listened we've also called for the
international deal that we need to see
around this we've not seen for example
the conservatives able to really work on
that deal that's needed with France we
would commit ourselves to getting that
quickly that International position I
mean the intransigence of the French
frankly will be there whether or not
it's a labor prime minister or a
conservative prime minister both sides
need to work together that's very very
clear but I have to say from the disc
discussions that we've had
internationally there hasn't been the
application that there needs to be from
the conservative government it needs to
come from all sides we need that
International deal and then of course
we've got to sort out the chaos in the
home office itself that's been a
dysfunctional Department particularly
over recent months only five percent of
people I believe who should have been
processed last year as Asylum Seekers
were we would get a grip on that and
sort it out but it isn't isn't part of
the problem that that as that as the
government says this this country is
seeing such a significant increase in
the number that are coming across and
that many of them are not you're
genuinely seeking Asylum that they are
economic migrants I mean the government
say of the 40 000 already this year 10
000 of those are Albanian men there is
no war there it is not by our and by our
it is not Bank from our our perspective
an unsafe country they are coming here
to to seek war I mean you know what
would labor do about that very specific
situation
well of course the government needs to
get a grip on this you know they
shouldn't just be complaining about it
they should be getting a grip as
kierstimer said yesterday and when it
comes specifically to that situation we
really need that International deal you
know it's terrible for Albania seeing a
lot of its Workforce actually leaving
the country we need to see that
International deal and as I mentioned
before from our discussions with other
nations we're not seeing the
conservatives engaging in that diplomacy
that's needed to broker those deals but
they're not doing other things either
they're not tackling debt sorry cracking
down on people Smugglers you know we've
said how they can do that they've not
taken those actions just on just on the
point of the of the huge numbers of
Albanian men coming here the local
you'll you'll have seen the letter this
morning from from local Authority
leaders in Kent they've said this we
have hundreds of mostly mostly Albanian
service units not claiming Asylum being
bailed and dropped at mid-kent train
stations with no follow-up where they go
or if the uh if they leave Kent now on
the one hand clearly they are not
fleeing War but it is entirely right
that they're being abandoned at train
stations in Kent in London we're also
healing as well and then the local
authorities of course have to try and
deal with that situation and this is
something that again Libra's warned
about for a very long time indeed we
didn't see the work with local
authorities that was necessary during
the crisis with Afghan refugees you know
this continues to be a problem but again
ultimately at the roots of this it's
those failures in the home office the
fact they're taking so long to process
people's claims you know years in many
cases I see that myself as a
constituency MP this has got so much
worse than it ever was under labor
governments really the government's got
to get a grip now can I just briefly ask
you about cop 27 Boris Johnson is going
uh we we had uh yeah a couple of days we
had a couple of days ago we then
discovered that Rishi sunak surprisingly
decided to go should cure Style terminal
be there well of course Ed miliband has
been an absolutely critical figure in
these different conferences for many
many years and Care's been absolutely
clear about his commitments to
preventing additional clothing about why
were you whining about the Prime
Minister not going he could have sent
his energy representative couldn't he is
climate representative well no because I
think actually the cop conference is a
conference Where Heads of states are
expected to be present but she soon act
wasn't standing up for our country when
he said he wouldn't go instead he seemed
to be driven more by his party and
trying to appease parts of his party you
know that ultimately is a decision
taking Forum it's that Forum where the
heads of state decide what they will do
in order to come to the climate crisis
that's why we should have had our prime
minister going from the very beginning
and of course just another you time from
Rishi on that I wonder if we might get
you to pop on one of your previous
Shadow ministerial hats and and talk to
us about the interest rates and we
aren't expecting that that historic
historic rise at least in the last at
every decade are we not approaching a
point where it is possible that we might
actually want to have a radical rethink
of the way in which the economy Works in
this whole country if ever there were a
time for some radical thinking when it
comes to free markets and capitalism
surely it is now and perhaps the only
party that has the opportunity to do so
is yours well that's why we've been
setting out a very clear plan for growth
you know we don't feel that growth comes
from the top down like conservatives
seem to believe that policy that
ultimately has been followed by
conservatives over the last 12 years
well it is radical to see every single
part of our country has the seeds for
growth we've got an incredible Workforce
in the UK and that's why we can have
radical plans you know labor said and
we're unique actually in the wild and
calling for this that we can get carbon
out of our energy Supply by 2030. we do
that we'll get bills down and we'll
create jobs is there no other way of
getting inflation under control that and
just having the bank of England continue
to hike interest rates because we know
what might happen if they if they go
past the point of no return well yes
there is a way to prevent that
development and to prevent it we need to
get growth going sustainably again
that's why we set out a plan for growth
I just mentioned that 2030 Target we've
also said however we want to see
communities having much more control
over the local economies we want to
scrap business rates get that burden off
our bricks and mortar businesses on our
high streets many other measures that
the government could adopt tomorrow if
they wanted to it's the conservatives
who are not willing to have that plan
for growth that Labor's setting out and
also it's great to have you in the
studio and I've got an umbrella and over
over in the office over there if you
need it to get back into Parliament it
was a bit rough outside but thanks for
coming in